this is Startalk welcome to Startalk I'm
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and we're
recording this out of the world
headquarters of Mashable right here in
New York City and today we're going to
tell you everything you ever wanted to
know and perhaps what you didn't even
want to know about the upcoming great
American Eclipse Mac merc and cliff
co-host is jut night
hey buddy Chuck love you man love you
too man and he also hosts the spin-off
of star talk playing with science that's
correct playing with science that's
right when you play my science I should
my permission of hahahahahaha as your
mother caught you playing with science
Chuck there's a lock on that door a
resident you know I can make you go
blind just remind you cannot in that
show so no plan with science as Gary
O'Reilly who was a former footballer and
Chuck Knights who is someone guy and we
actually have different athletes on the
show and we take what what somebody said
where's jocks and geeks collide with how
the concussion propel without a
concussion it's amazing and so what we
do is we take sports and science and we
break down the science in the sport and
we discuss the sports as well as a lot
that's a recent spin-off that's why I'm
still learning about what you guys
cooked up over there so but thanks for
joining us and you know what we have
today by video call we have an expert
guest is my friend and colleague and an
associate at the Hayden Planetarium Joe
rail Joe thanks for betting on just to
get some of your background here your
broadcast meteorologists and you wrote
the children's book looking up the
science of stargazing and so absolutely
yeah yeah it's good good to have you
always good to get your input on
nighttime cosmic phenomena in this case
it would be daytime phenomena and in
particular this episode of star talk is
officially designated a cosmic queries
just on the Eclipse test so yes so we'll
go to cosmic queries intermittently but
I want to get sort of Jo in the mix here
Jo I seen one eclipse in my life you've
seen some uncountable number of eclipses
how many total minutes of totality have
you been steeped in I have seen eleven
this will be I'll make it an even dozen
with the coming great American Eclipse
and you know that that number may sound
very impressive to a lot of your viewers
Neil but and it was impressive 40 years
ago but there are people out there who
have seen for many for many more than I
have some people seem 2025 and dr.
Brenda I grew up with in the Bronx your
favorite borough and I drink Glenn
Schneider he has seen 33 this will be
his 30 port eclipse of the Sun so okay
come on the stroke well toast I've
always said total eclipses when you see
it first
it's like potato chips you become
addicted you have to have more and quite
obviously I've been addicted because
I've seen 11 this will be my 12th and
then I hope to see a lot more before I
depart this earth well I'll be going
media silent during the Eclipse which
will force the media into the thousands
of people who walk this land right who
have expertise sufficient to deliver an
interview with the press you know they
still call you I don't know that right
seriously no no because I I'm bigoted
lazy and just call me because I live
here in New York City and they know I
give them a sound bite but this this
event will sell itself and so that's why
I don't need to be there and my location
is a state secret oh really
you will not know where I am I'm ever
going to be you'll know I'll be in the
path to a talent but you all know where
I'm on earth or my elevation a lover and
you know what's funny is I get asked
every day on Twitter or where you are
going to go watch the Eclipse and to
which I indicate you get tortured I
don't want you to know right well I tell
people all the time Neal doesn't like me
he doesn't nothing
work together what is your problem so
Joe I'm looking at this year but your
office in the back there with all these
degrees on the wall so just wicked smack
yeah and you've got a total eclipse in
the upper corner is that a black hole no
that's that's a view of the total
eclipse of the Sun I don't know exactly
I actually have a total eclipse an
annular eclipse and I have an eclipse
that was taken by a gentleman from the
amateur astronomers Association right
here in New York he is no longer with us
that dates back to 1945 over Montana the
Rising Sun over the hills of Montana
it's a crescent Sun and a few minutes
after sunrise it went into total eclipse
they're they're amazing dealers and I've
indicated that you can't beat that it's
like the sunrise and or is it Nature's
Way of saying I just robbed you of a
sudden it's interesting that the next
total eclipse the Sun over little old
New York will be on Tuesday May first
twenty seventy nine and that happens
right after the Sun comes up so it is
clear that morning it'll be a most
probably the most unusual sunrise in New
York history again if it happens to be
clear we cannot like wrong I mean I was
sort of locked my calories I were thrown
out so Joe spend a minute just
describing what the hell is going to
happen well actually at the very
beginning you don't even know that it's
happening if you're not aware that
there's an eclipse that is going to take
place a total eclipse of the Sun what
happens is that the move against the
move in front of the Sun and actually
you have to have a considerable amount
of the Sun cover before you start
noticing that something's eerie is
happening the landscape after about 70
to 80 percent of coverage the landscape
begins to take on kind of a weird look
more of a yellowish color almost like a
dusty Twilight beginning to descend upon
the entire region but it's not until
that last 30 seconds the last 30 seconds
before totality that it really gets
crazy it's almost like being at a
Broadway play curtain time at a Broadway
play and
you know you've been to a Broadway play
they lower the lights during quickly
just in the shows about to begin
that's kind of like what it is just
before totality all of a sudden the sky
begins to darken very quickly and then
suddenly up in the sky where there was
once a brilliant ball of light the Sun
you now have this strange eye if you
will wind with fire appealing in the
middle of the sky and stars come out the
sky gets a quality similar to Twilight
half an hour or 45 minutes after sundown
and it's just an awesome awesome
spectacle and it only plants for
depending upon where you are in the
Eclipse tab only about a minute or two
in this case at most two minutes and 40
seconds and then after that we just
reverse the procedure in 30 seconds up
comes the lights and within a minute or
two it's almost as if there were nothing
had happened prior it's back to a normal
sunny day and it just it floors
everybody who sees it for the first time
and I think a lot of people are going to
be just stunned about what what's going
to occur on August 21st at I'd streets
across the United States goes to goes so
so Joe I hadn't appreciated this until
you just said it now we there's nothing
in life experience that darkens a
daytime sky as quickly as the last few
seconds of the partial phases of a total
eclipse because when the Sun sets it's
slightly darker but it's not pitch-black
right and some people think it gets
immediately dark at sunset right because
they've never paid attention exactly
right
I've had lawyers call me up and say
someone is testifying that they couldn't
see anything when they were driving
because it was five minutes after sunset
I say there's a lot up here we have an
eclipse where a few percent of the Sun
exposed is sufficient to just be kind of
bright daylight and then damn darkness
sadness descends upon the deep a lot of
people a lot of people say you know
what's the big difference I'm going to
see a 95 or 97 percent partial eclipses
they're really the necessity to get
to the zone words can be total and my
answer to that is most unequivocally yes
yes you do want to get into the total
band of totality because if you don't
you're going to miss out on a lot of
people are amazed even if you just
mentioned Neil the final couple of
percent of sunlight even it's a razor
thin Crescent still puts out a large
amount of sunlight a large amount of
illumination you got to shut off every
little bit of the Sun in order to
appreciate just how much darker it gets
and with that few percentage points of
sunlight remaining you don't see the
stars come out you don't get that
dramatic sunset and sunrise color
[ __ ] the horizon and you don't see
that that shadow the lunar shadow comes
sweeping in and over you like somebody
throw in the blanket over your head you
really miss out unless you get into that
zone of totality and I think I think
that's going to lead to a to a
tremendous number of people trying to do
that on the Monday the 21st of August so
it's been said once and I forgot who
said it and I would have to paraphrase
it so it's the difference between seeing
a partial eclipse and seeing a total
eclipse mm-hmm
is equivalent to the difference between
kissing your loved one mm-hmm and having
sex with your loved one I love this
analogy freaking because you they're
both pleasing or pleasing but I'll take
either one you you cannot extrapolate
right from the kiss to sex there's no
right hat yes to land there right it is
a completely it's completely more
absolutely absolute log is here yes
exactly it is it is right yeah yeah
exactly
one is like eating the best most exotic
delicacy you could ever find and the
other is like licking carpet so we need
carpet is on point you I mean yeah that
sure they both have to be good at both
everything said that's why yeah you're
right
this analogy was good I just screwed it
up you just messed up bad about being
outside you know you before World Series
seeing a partial eclipse is like being
in the parking lot
seeing a total eclipse is taking your
ticket walking into the stadium and
sitting down to the box seat and getting
ready to actually watch physically the
game and dandled exciting and then
having sex in the seventh-inning stretch
there you go now we got total eclipse
what makes this America's eclipse it's
called it's being called the great
American Eclipse because number one is
the first time since 1918 that this
eclipse is going to be going from coast
to coast in 1918 we had one that came in
from the Pacific coast and went across
the United States ended up going through
Florida exiting out over the Bahamas in
1918 so that was a full American eclipse
because it did touch places outside of
American soil
this one is being called the great
American Eclipse because we're the only
hunting country we are the hosts of this
Eclipse there have been other eclipses
in the past like for example in 1970
there was one that went through Mexico
went up along the eastern seaboard of
the United States men went into eastern
Canada the Maritimes 1979 went over the
Pacific in seven eclipses that was me
Carly fighter quicks correct no I think
the coral excitement eclipse was 1972
actually I could have been the 1970
Eclipse if you did the 19 City believe
the diagnosis all in certain aliens just
have to the Carly Simon clip what is
that an eclipse that looks at your
intent by oh you think this is about
Cuba what kind of a book the calling by
minutes well okay Joe claim for so be
right I see this song you're the Carly
Simon song you're so gain and she
apparently writes about somebody some
mysterious person who went to fly his
Lear jet to Nova Scotia to see a total
eclipse of the Sun Tom American one
lyric in the song okay that could have
been one of three eclipses there was one
over Nova Scotia in 1963 there was one
in 1970 either
we think it was the one in 1972 July
that was also my very first total
eclipse I saw that one came back but
after passed over me in Quebec I went
across Nova Scotia and I think the song
Carly Simon song was a hit the following
year in 1973 which makes me think that
maybe she was talking about that 1972 or
maybe she was just making the whole
thing up who knows
Java songs about Ned Beatty I think so
no I'm sorry
Warren Beatty no one different yet
nobody would ever write a song is my
problem this eclipse is going to be the
great American Eclipse because we are
the host country there is no other
country that we're sharing this eclipse
with and the last time that happened was
before this country became a country if
you go back over the various manuals
that show you tracks of past eclipses
historical eclipses the last time this
country you use the political boundaries
had an eclipse all to its own was back
in here 1245 ad so and that was of
course before the United States existed
so this is the very first time that we
are the sole country and there are
countries people from all over the world
that are going to be converging on just
the United States with this great
American eclipse it's just one more way
that we're making America great again
I'm taking total credit for the Eclipse
perfected by the way the D did you know
that Donald Trump president Donald Trump
was born on the day in the cliffs that
name was that one on the date that maybe
was born on the day he was born on the
day of a total eclipse of the moon
Donald Trump I haven't had a chance to
look and see if any of the president has
had a total eclipse or any influence on
on his birthday but Donald Trump has
that recognition of being born on the
Dame when there was a total eclipse of
the moon just to be clear an eclipse of
the moon takes place at the moon right
an eclipse of the Sun takes place at the
earth so if you are anywhere on the side
of the earth that sees the moon being
eclipsed that you'll see the total
eclipse of the moon
okay that's so anyone so that's a lot of
people if it could be that too right
absolutely so it's not as rare a thing
right to be born under an eclipsing moon
as it is to be born under clip Singh son
by the way I'm so great I've lock out
the Sun so Gerald is the sea so what's
an average totality among eclipses
relative to this one well I mean it's I
think even just a one second total
eclipse is more amazing than anything
that you love to see in terms of our
partial eclipses and this one this one
actually been telling people this is
actually the appetizer this upcoming
eclipse this year because there's going
to be another total eclipse over the
United States in 2024 only seven years
down the road and that Eclipse is going
to be better in the sense that the path
the area of visibility of the total
phase of the Eclipse is going to be
bigger as I mentioned earlier this one
is not going to last longer than two
minutes and 40 seconds the one in 2024
is going to last in some places over
four minutes so whereas people will
probably get turned on when they see
this Eclipse in 2017 and the first thing
out of the amounts will say when can I
see another one seven years from now in
2024 you'll get another one and that one
will be even better much better in fact
circumstance of circumstances than what
we're going to see this year in 2017 so
you get these differences because of the
distance that the moon is from Earth
that is not constant so is that because
it's like what what would you call it is
it like a depth of field when you're
looking at something from a distance and
you're like you use your thumb to block
it out that type of deal okay but so so
yeah if the moon is caused in the moon's
be elliptical orbit around the earth if
we get an eclipse when the moon is
closer to Earth right then the moon is
bigger in the sky right and if at that
time we are farther from the Sun because
our orbit around the Sun is also
elliptical correct so the Eclipse that I
saw way back when had the moon at one of
its closest times to Earth and earth at
one of its farthest distances from the
Sun aha so it took a long time for the
Sun
for the movement to pass in front of the
Sun so okay that's it so my Eclipse at
peak was 7 minutes and 14 seconds oh my
god that is a major so that's at peak
but we couldn't go to rivers peaking
because there was a dust storm picking
up over this era okay and so we sort off
off more off the coast so mine was 6
minutes and 20 seconds
speaking of which yes and since Joe is
meteorologists can is there a place
where you don't want to go because if
it's cloudy you are screwed we will
touch the mountain man when we come back
from this commercial break on Startalk
hey everybody just reminding you that
everything that we do can be found on
Startalk all-access comm even things
that can't be found anywhere else like
exclusive original content so make sure
you go to Startalk all-access comm and
subscribe
we're back on Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson Chuck nice ain't tweeting a truck
Trek nice comic thank you sorry happy
man on Twitter we've got with us on
video call the one the only the guy who
knows the nice guy better than anyone
I've ever met Joe Rael associated the
Hayden Planetarium and he's a
meteorologist who'd like Lifetime
television meteorologist yeah that
meteorologists voice too he does let me
hear some of that voice do I this
morning for breakfast I had some eggs
for tissa tea very nice so just before
the break we were trying to get it
understand a couple of things let me let
me back up for a minute yeah today
people travel with much greater ease
than at any time in the history of
eclipses so is it possible that this
eclipse will be the most watch ever in
the history of civilization mmm because
this is America and everybody got a car
right and if you don't drive you have a
plane and whatever and we all will just
gather in this path of totality this
narrow path across the country well Neil
there are 12 million people who already
were to ously live in the zone of
totality totality exactly it's 70 miles
wide it's 2,500 miles long stretching
from Oregon to South Carolina however
there are an estimated 220 million
people that's more than two-thirds of
the total population of the United
States 220 million are within a one
day's drive 500 miles of the total
eclipse path which leads one to wonder
just how many people either late that
Sunday night the night before or early
that Monday morning the 21st of August
are going to suddenly decide hey let's
let's jump in the car and go and see
that total eclipse so it's going to be
interesting to see there there are a lot
of impact of the 14 states that are in
the totality zone the VOT Department of
traffic has issued in all of those
states warnings as if it were almost
like a category three hurricane heading
in their direction
they are warning about major traffic
jams stock up on food because it could
be in your car for a long time and even
on some of the major interstate roads
like I 85 in Georgia or i-5 and Oregon
they're anticipating traffic tie-ups
that they had never seen before for all
these people trying to jockey into
position to see the total eclipse that
day so so it's possible that 200 million
people will see this quote do you think
that's more than any previous eclipse
has ever been witnessed I'm not sure I
know that in 1991 does the Mexico so
know for that eclipse the 1991 eclipse
was related to the one that you saw Anil
and that back in the 70 to say Cerie
long eclipse yeah it was it was about
seven minutes long and passed over
Mexico City the entire population of
Mexico City was treated to a total
eclipse and I believe at that time the
population of Mexico City in one sitting
was like 23 million people Wow
so it may not be necessarily in one
sitting for this eclipse but certainly a
lot of people travel into the totality
path this could very well be indeed the
most beautiful it's total eclipse in in
modern history no in all of history
ellos district yes yes and if I remember
the 1991 eclipse also went across Mauna
Kea Hawaii and the telescope was able to
observe it from there wasn't that the
same eclipse yeah in fact it passed over
the Big Island of Hawaii and Mauna Kea
is there on the top of that extinct
volcanic cone the problem was they saw
it at Mauna Kea but all the people who
went to Hawaii to see that Eclipse or
most people went to Hawaii didn't the
easy that prior to the Eclipse the
meteorologists and climatologists said
oh does at 95% chance of clear weather
for the Eclipse because in July that was
the month that the Eclipse occurred they
get the trade winds and when the trade
winds blow usually the weather is clear
but unfortunately on the day of the
Eclipse it was the other 5% there was
some sort of disturbance which clouded
things over and people actually got
rained on and ye one person actually
walked away after that Anthony Eclipse
and said the total eclipse was a total
bust
at least for Hawaiian so they look under
way through monetary and objects yeah
they're going to blame you you know that
right they're all going to blame you you
know that you look at all the weather
records you can see you can see where
the best place is based upon long-term
records but it doesn't always work out
that way in fact Robert Heinlein who was
a very famous science fiction writer
once said and it's absolutely true
Simon is what you expect but weather is
what you get so you may be in a place
where the climatology says it'll be
great for viewing the eclipse but the
weather it makes up its own mind if it
decides to be cloudy that day and you
don't see it so those okay so before we
get to cosmic queries because this is a
cosmic we're dissing ya Joe what's spend
a minute explaining what we mean by
family's other klutzes and how there can
be a series of eclipses that all related
to one another
there is a there's a family or a cycle
that was known that to the ancient
called Ian's
and Babylonians thousands of years ago
known as the Saros cycle and what this
is is that it's a there are three
different lunar cycles that seem to come
together it's kind of like hitting the
jackpot let's say on a slot machine
these three cycles involve the position
of the moon and its orbit relative to
the earth whether it's closer or farther
away the lunar month also known as the
synodic month the these cycles will come
together and it's called the Saros cycle
service means repetition and eclipses
repeat after about 18 years and ten or
eleven and one-third days that one third
of a day is important however because
when the Eclipse returns after 18 some
odd years the earth and at one third of
a day has turned 120 degrees in its
rotation cycle and so while the Eclipse
is going to return it will not return to
the same part of the world that it was
seen 18 years previous vince eclipse
coming up for example the great American
Eclipse 18 years ago 18 years and about
11 years 11 and third days ago that
eclipse occurred over Europe well now 18
years later 18 years and 10
days later the earth has turned 120
degrees so now it's not over Europe this
time it's our turn here in the United
States or North America to see that
Eclipse and in another 18 plus years the
earth will turn again one third of a way
around so when this eclipse returns in
18 years that's in the year 2035 or
won't be visible over North America
it'll probably be passing over the
Pacific Ocean or parts of Asia but this
cycle was known thousands of years ago
to the ancient sky watchers and they
were able to make some pretty good
predictions just by knowing about the
repetition of this Eclipse cycle and
being able to anticipate when it flips
as we're going to occur so the cuts that
I saw was in July of 1973 because that's
how old I am okay at 18 and 2/3 years to
that you get to the 1991 Eclipse yeah so
that all works out so to check once you
give us a question all right why don't
we start off and we'll of course we
always start with one of our patreon
patron questions because these are the
people that support us financially and
they block their way into the question
list I say it all the time just like
your Congressman we can be bought all
right yeah this is will Judy and will
Judy says this start Judy well now I'm
confused
it could be Judy well but it or will
Judy I don't know anyone for last name
of Judy they're really saying well maybe
I'm saying that wrong because it's je
ugy so it's judy judy judy all right all
right so where are you all going to
watch this beautiful event I will be in
South Carolina where there is some great
barbecue
would you mind meeting me there for a
beer I looked it up we already discussed
the fact that you're not going you're in
a secret super secret okay with
government secret spot correctly the Joe
I think South Carolina has like the
least positive rutter prospects of the
entire Trek because that track is that
correct yeah unfortunately places that
are nearer to the Atlantic coast are
subjected to a number of things that if
you've ever been down in South Carolina
and August you know number one it's
number two in tends to be rather humid
and in the afternoon hours especially
which is when this eclipse is going to
occur there tends to be showers and
thunderstorms that pop up so it's not
the best place to be but still even if
you see a total eclipse of the Sun and
it happens to be cloudy and that has
happened to me once out of the eleven
times that I've seen total eclipses it's
still a very very dramatic sight to see
of course you don't want to be deprived
of a view of the beautiful corona the
outer atmosphere of the Sun that appears
during totality but down in South
Carolina
hopefully it the weather will be cleared
up you to see that but again in the
summertime not really the best weather
prospects for Russell here just really
jump make sure the barbecue is good
there you go
all right this is Eric Barda coming to
us from Facebook I'm aware that the moon
is receding from the earth at a rate of
a couple inches per year how long will
it be until the moon's orbit has moved
too far to have anymore
Toller total solar eclipses ooh what a
incredible work so the moon is getting
smaller and smaller that means there
will be a day where the moon will never
in its orbit be large enough to
completely cover the Sun right we'll
still have eclipses right they just
won't be told us won't be told in fact
we this the word for ring is annulus
Angeles that's a word for live Latin for
a ring right and so one of the kinds of
eclipses is an annular eclipse annular
right right and where the Sun the moon
goes in the center of the Sun you see a
ring or sunlight so Joanne who done this
calculation I haven't there's a there's
a gentleman who lives in Belgium who's
world-renowned he's a very famous
calculator of celestial mechanics Jean
and may use and doctor may use has done
the calculation and he says that
sometime about a billion or so years
from now the moon will indeed be too far
away to create total eclipses actually
he says that is going to be a few
million years where it's going to
alternate where it'll be possible and
then not possible you'll get periods
where the you'll go to periods where the
moon will be too far away and it'll just
be close enough to cover the
but in about a billion years or so
according to Duncan they use that will
be the time when eclipses of the song
total eclipse of the Sun will just be a
thing of the past so enjoy these as
spectacles wildly last because whatever
engineers they're gonna make by the way
four billion years ago when the moon
formed it was 20 times larger in the sky
than it is now Wow
so you would have some serious eclipses
every no not an eclipse again I got it
exactly yeah I got to finish my homework
yeah okay so where'd the light go again
I'm paying this bill who is not paying
this so yeah so the mood was spiraling
away over the billions of years right
but the rate at which it spirals away
will get slower so it was it was
happening fast long ago yeah yeah so
that makes me curious about eclipses
from the standpoint of other planets so
if there is there another planet where
it seems as though we are uniquely
situated for eclipses that the total
solar eclipses the way they happen here
if they're another planet in our solar
system that might have maybe a couple
moons that do the same thing or that
aligned at the same time or you know
that might give us some some different
configurations of a kind of clips are
you interjecting your own question from
the cosmic where I am interject okay
that's allowed because you're close
okay that's allowed of so an interesting
fact about the moon and the Sun is the
number 300 Joe that the moon is the Sun
is 300 times farther away than the moon
is and the Sun is I think it's 400 for
the Sun is 400 times farther away from
us than the moon is okay and the Sun is
400 times larger than the moon so
Hansel's straight out and they fit
behind there for that
so what anybody else have that ratio in
the whole solar system go I don't think
so and there are so many moons now I
mean when you and I were growing up neo
LED was so easy Jupiter had 12 Saturn
and 10 will doesn't move you know these
now now you just Saturday low ends like
67 moons and tempera has like a similar
amount
but I think all of those satellites then
going around all the other planets are
probably too small to create the same
type of effect as what we have here are
as seen from the earth in fact you might
even call the Earth Moon system a double
planet there's no moon that is
proportionally some larger size as our
Moon is relative to the earth as opposed
to all the other planets in the solar
system that had satellites to create the
spectacle of the total eclipse of the
Sun now before 2006 we would have said
Pluto has a larger moon relative to
itself but since it's not a planet
heading right it's not in his answer is
that right because Pluto's moon Charon
is even bigger compared to Pluto than
our moon is compared to us right
so the size of distance ratio for Pluto
if it were a planet if you take that ice
ball might makes uniquely situated to
have what to experience yeah I say no no
but the Sun is really really small out
there so edge is so far away so far away
so in a way it doesn't really send you
get an eclipse but if the eclipsing if
the object passing between you and the
Sun is really really large like you're
not gonna get the beautiful corona yeah
because that's right adjacent to the
edge of the Sun it's like just closing
your eyes because it's just blocking
everything right at that point exactly
Wow exactly dude that was great okay so
one minute what we got one minute left
segment right you know what so since we
got one minute left I'm going to give
you a yeah okay I got to do this because
it's I got to ask you this question just
because Andrew Hanks wants to know that
and I'm taking them seriously okay will
the Sun about the moon when it passes in
front of it I'm I'm not too keen on
cheese and I don't fancy it raining down
on me when I when I go shopping I did
not make that up
Andrew Hanks wants to know will the moon
as well the Sun smells blue Texas okay
here's the thing given the season given
how many people sink today the earth is
flat right this is a high level question
I'm impressed we're getting better Elise
is thinking about the thermodynamics of
the situation absolutely
see that's why I asked because I knew it
and no matter what Neil will find a way
to answer someone's question I don't
care how stupid it is okay and I know
they say there's no such thing as stupid
question but the people who say that are
stupid so I said yeah I'll take this one
so here it is so on the side of the moon
that is facing the Sun it's a couple
hundred degrees it's very hot very hot
and it will melt almost any thing you
would eat like cheese would just be
melted by and so the moon were made of
cheese half it would just melt off the
face right right so but now the moon is
turning and it takes a month to turn
turns out and because this matches the
time it takes to go around the earth so
on the side where the Sun is not shining
it's like alcohol how it's called is
again on the dark side with the unlit
side of the moon about two hundred and
fifty below zero zero zero so that will
freeze it right back up right right so
so we have so if you want to live on the
moon and not melt or freeze you want to
be in a like a rotisserie right at the
boundary lighted you just want to find
that line of light and a god and spin
around it rotate so you decided it's
baked is share is exchanged
intermittently beside this frozen and
that way you stay one one temperature
and see that's why I ask these questions
because we still learn something after
all that's okay we're going to take a
break we'll come back to cosmic queries
on the great American Eclipse with my
friend and colleague and I'm Hayden
associate Jo rail on video call we'll be
right back
hey Chuck knives here you know a total
solar eclipse blocked out the Sun so
allow me to enlighten you on a couple of
things did you like what I did just
there thing one playing with science is
a new show under the Startalk umbrella
featuring Gary O'Reilly a former
professional footballer and yours truly
join us as we break down the science of
sports it's where jocks and geeks
collide without a concussion and it's
loads of fun thing - everything that we
do can be found on Startalk all-access
comm that's right in audio and video
form I don't care what it is if we've
done it it will be on Startalk
all-access comm + full interviews that
can't be found anywhere else and
exclusive original content that we make
just for you because you subscribe to
Startalk all-access comm so do me a
favor click on the link or click on the
link I don't know where it is
these glasses are blinding me maybe it's
because they're not solar eclipse
approved I think I'm losing vision but
click on the link and subscribe and
watch me go blind Startalk all-access
calm
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
edition special topic a merc great
Eclipse America Monday August 21st
Dateline 2017 I got Chuck nice I got Joe
ray o on video call an associate that
the Hayden Planetarium might go to man
for everything night sky and in this
particular case its base guy people are
the next questions and I just make one
suggestion to anyone who's watching
who's planning to see this eclipse the
first Eclipse that he or she has ever
seen a lot of people are going to try to
photograph this Eclipse and my
suggestion to any first-timer is don't
bother taking pictures you want to drink
in every single last second of the total
days of the eclipse you don't want to
fumble around with your iPhone you don't
want to maybe add a camera and looking
for the aperture settings or whatever
you just want to sit and watch and enjoy
this entire beautiful spectacle because
I have told people before Chuck and Neil
trying to photograph your very first
total eclipse of the Sun like your first
girlfriend you're not very good at it
it's over very quickly and you just want
to do it all over again and that's it's
that kind of it and okay so this is like
your first girlfriend do you cry when
it's over because that was not here I
will add that lately people have been
using their smartphone to take video of
extraordinary events that are in front
of them and so here's something
extraordinary in front of them and
they're looking at a 2 inch screen of
the extraordinary event right so that in
fact the cost of keeping a video of it
is having missed the event entirely
absolutely that's the expense of the
expense of having that video if you
actually miss the thing that you would
answer things Isis with some event where
the Pope was going bad right anybody
looking at the Pope through the thing
right look at the man that just oh he's
right there it's right here right yes so
maybe you might want to commit this
event to your own memory I tell you what
here's the suggestion there are going to
be across the path of totality along the
path
so many professional photographers who
are going to photograph the event and
video the event right go watch it and
then buy their photo we need your wimpy
ass Go Go
just to be like but and then put it out
right and people say oh what's that oh
that's all I saw I saw the [ __ ] lips
and then then you have a record of the
Eclipse but from from a professional
standard you go sell right there we go
this is heat McCasland and heat would
like to know this coming to us from
Facebook for astronauts watching from
the ISS will any man-made lights be
visible to the naked eye in the Umbria
of the Eclipse mmm interesting question
so Joe they believe it or not they have
already done the computations and the
astronauts on board the ISS will see the
Eclipse on three separate locations or
three separate orbits of the earth they
will not see a total eclipse but they
will see in the most extreme cases
something like 80% partial eclipse and
when they look down on the earth what
they will see will be the in essence
what loves to be like a black stain that
is projected upon the surface of the
earth be it on the ocean or as its
passing over the United States in that
black stain of course is the Earth's
that is the moon's Umbra the dark shadow
that's going to create the total eclipse
of the Sun I think only one time in the
history of manned spaceflight
I think it was Gemini 12 two astronauts
circling the earth back in 1966 did
briefly for a few seconds see a total
eclipse of the Sun as they passed into
the moon shot' I think one of those
astronauts in fact was Buzz Aldrin the
second man to walk on the moon but it's
I guess difficult to you know get the
the space vehicle involved as it's
circling the earth getting into the
shadow of the moon but they will be able
to see from the International Space
Station
what's going on down there with that
black shadow moving over the earth and
in the sky with the moon passing across
the base of the Sun so Joe how fast is
the shadow moving on Earth's surface
well the moon goes around the earth at a
speed of about 2,300 miles per hour
you would think that that would be the
speed as it's moving across the surface
of the earth but that's not true because
we here on the earth or is also there
turning earth yeah and and so we are
moving and we are in some cases staying
with the shadow or period of time
especially if the shadow is passing over
the equatorial regions we could stay
with it and help to slow the movement of
the shadow across the earth down in this
particular case the shadow as it goes
from coast to coast across the United
States will be moving roughly at an
average speed of about 16 or 1700 miles
per hour it will be moving actually
slower over Tennessee and Kentucky and a
bit faster as it's entering the United
States from the Pacific coast but still
rather rapid speed and even if you had a
you know one of those supersonic
transport planes you wouldn't be able to
stay in it forever the moment eventually
is going to win out with that with that
fast movement one of my favorite things
to look for particularly the cliffs is
where this shadow is not as big as the
one that I had seen so the cliff is
shorter my favorite thing is to watch
the shadow approach from the horizon
nice moving at 1,700 miles an hour it's
this cut through the atmosphere and it
is dark in the center yet it is Twilight
on each side of it and here it comes
with then you no one's going to be
looking at it because all gonna be
looking up but the old-timers who've
seen 10 a dozen eclipses the greedy ones
we know the other stuff to look at right
that's what the decide show that makes
up the total circus that this is at
least what else you have all right here
we go Jeff so stars check so start yet
wants to know this does I'm sorry I put
your Nick your name Jeff if you didn't
we would not know who you were here we
go Jeff wants to know this does the
solar eclipse give our ground-based
telescopes an enhanced view of distant
objects due to gravitational lensing
so our is there any enhanced view of
what we're looking out past during the
Eclipse and wasn't there I mean isn't
that how we prove I'm Stein right about
his you remember this in the year
nineteen nineteen Coretta Sir Arthur
Eddington led an expedition yeah to test
this three year old prediction that
gravity would bend the path of light so
severe gravity would bend it noticeably
and they wanted to do it in Eclipse in
1918 but the first world war was the
Great War was still interfering with
material and personnel movement so they
had to wait until 1919 and sure enough
they made the measurements the Stars
whose light passed near the edge of the
Sun which you wouldn't otherwise be able
to see in the daytime or when we're not
even questioning right right so the
positions of those stars were slightly
different then when they were six months
later when you would observe them in the
dark of night and that bending confirmed
Einstein's general theory of relativity
right so that's exactly how that played
out super cool yeah and also you got
super cool stuff give me some more
all right Allen Pulaski from Facebook
would like to know this Harry Neil can
you please explain why there is no dark
side of the moon and why it isn't all
dark those are the last two phrases in
Pink Floyd's Dark Side of the Moon song
of the Dark Side of the Moon album from
1973 oh really yes I did at the end of
that song it says there is no Dark Side
of the Moon it's all dark oh but it's
wait you got to listen you gotta like
such a headphone moment yeah okay I've
heard the song no no yeah just check it
out again yeah okay so I'm weird memory
of cosmic references in the in the
history of all the rock of all pop of
all rock and roll oh nice so yeah so the
moon only ever shows one face to us okay
there is a far side and a near side for
that reason but all sides of them to get
some way a day on the moon daytime in
the moon is about 15 days long and then
fifteen days of night so so it's a long
day and when it's night is night for 15
days but it's not eternally dark so it
is a misunderstanding and I blame Pink
Floyd for that I undo they're way more
influential than I ever was just in
naming their so so you know who got it
right who got it right um the cartoonist
Gary Larson Oh the name of his cartoon
is clogged up no wait the far side all
the power five dots I see there's a
scientifically literate person
referencing outside because there's a
far side and there's a near side here is
the far side near sighs because it's a
tidally locked tightly locked right they
get always so it is turning it's turning
but it's just showing Maddie not exactly
the same round we are or what we tidally
locked in it okay so we slow that we
slow the moon down yeah but now spinning
like anybody else in town okay we slowed
it down and now it's walk and we'll stay
that way forever
Wow it's trying to timely lock us okay
wait a minute now that we can't stamp we
can't stand for that now that'll take
longer to do that than they expect at
age of the Sun the life expectancy is so
weak so we cool okay good I don't see ya
all right John Reinhold what's to know
this will there be a measurable error
temperature difference during the Eclair
oh yes there most definitely will in
fact in the middle part of the country
where we'll be happening at midday or
actually in the eastern half of the
country where we happening like two or
three o'clock in Hampton is if there's
enough of the Sun covered 80 90 percent
or be in total you could get a
temperature drop of three four five
degrees or more and as the air actually
begins to contract with that cooling of
the atmosphere that helps to pull in the
winds from all directions that's why
sometimes when you get the midpoint of a
major Eclipse a cool breeze suddenly
starts to spring up so most definitely
maybe not so much in the in the western
United States will be during the morning
hours and there hasn't been enough
heating taking place yet but most
definitely in the middle part of the
country and in the eastern part of the
country you will get a noticeable
temperature drop it's a round or soon
after the point of minute clips maximum
occur only an actual air temperature
there's also
once the Sun is blocked you know we're
getting radiant heat okay right you ever
notice if someone walks between you and
a fireplace you feel instantly cold
absolutely well the air temperature is
the same that's true
the enormous unchanged in that instant
oh it's the heat emanating from the
finest that photons coming from the fire
touching your skin and getting absorbed
has nothing to do with the temperature
the air so you blot out the Sun you not
only get the cooling that Joe is talking
about you're going to the absence of
photons that you had been basking this
is why shade is cooler than non shade in
the summertime that's the only reason
why it's just blocking those it's just
blocking this extra source of heat to
you right the shade is not really cooler
right then being out into sunlight if
you're walking in and out of shade back
and forth the hair is all mixed
I can't wait to lay by a fire with my
wife the next time we like baby that's
not heat this that's my full-time feel
that girl look feel my phone dodging my
photon header a good time for one more
eye here we go here we go this is
actually important James Cultus
asking a very important question here
hey Neil are you going to watch the
Eclipse in person of which we know you
are if so and Joe can chime in on this
too please tell me what gear you will
use should we watch through binoculars
telescopes glasses wine glass of wine
out hook Tennyson Joe we didn't spend
any time on this give it give it some
concluding comments on what's the best
way to view the Eclipse although the
best way I you know everybody has been
surrounding around for Eclipse glasses
and in fact believe it or not now there
are knockoff Eclipse glasses these
glasses are made either of mylar or
special plastic called polymer and they
have been tested there have been
certified but there are some places that
haven't been certified they could have a
scratch in them got to be very very
careful with that a lot of these
knockoffs suddenly appeared over the
last couple of three weeks you don't
have to look directly at the Sun however
if you do you can also use welder's
glass number 13 and number 14 welder's
can get that in any hardware store or
welding supply store it'll turn the Sun
green when you look through it but it
will be enough so that you'll be able to
see it safely it blocks out both the
visible
I ran an ultraviolet radiations but if
you don't even want to look at the Sun
directly you can just find a shade tree
I think it's most delightful the light
going through these phases in between
the leaves project or dapple the ground
with hundreds of these images of the sun
on the ground and if there's a lung
freeze they almost seem like they're
twinkling it's the same methodology as
when you're doing a pinhole image of the
Sun you let the sun's light go through a
pinhole and then you hold a card or a
piece of paper about two or three feet
away from the pinhole and you can see
the image projected on that screen using
the pinhole image the trees do it for
you naturally and by the way you can
also use a mirror believe it or not if
you have like let's say compact mirror
or small mirror just punch a hole in a
piece of construction paper put it over
the mirror and then turn the mirror to
the Sun you can project that image onto
let's say the side of a house and it
will project the exact same image that's
happening up in the sky another very
safe way of looking at it you don't have
to worry about blinding yourself you
just look at that projected image using
the mirror so there's number of safe
ways don't look at it with sunglasses
don't look at it directly don't you
smoke glass that just transmits the
ultraviolet infrared radiation into your
eye and since your eyes don't can't
sense pain your eyes if you're looking
through a piece of smoked glass for
example are being fried without your
being aware of it you'll learn about it
later when you see a hole and you can't
see anything anymore in that particular
spot we looking at the Sun during
totality look at the Sun directly that's
the only time that you could look
directly at the Sun during an eclipse is
during totality you know Charles Schultz
bless his soul the man who created
peanuts back in 1963 he did a six story
arc of comic strips with the Peanuts
characters looking up at the anybody to
be eclipsed and Linus in you remember
Linus who is always the voice of reason
among the peanuts kids he said in one of
those comic strips it's dangerous to
look at the Sun during an eclipse and
especially dangerous when it's a total
eclipse given the impression that the
worst time to look is during totality
Linus you're wrong you
then look directly at the Sun during the
total phase only of the Eclipse that's a
time to take your eyewear off put down
the projected cards and look directly
over the Sun that will give you a best
spectacular people make sure that when
the Sun begins to emerge that you put
those glasses back on again because
again even that slight little sliver of
someone is still dangerous yet but in
all fairness to Linus the reason why he
thought thought that is because Snoopy
looked at it before it was in its
totality and that's why he wears those
sunglasses and they call him Joe cool
it's not so blind this one line a quick
couple of tidbits just to end the show
it's got the two parts of the shadow the
darkest part of the Umbra depth totality
and the surrounding areas that Penn
Umbra and which is where part of the Sun
is is covered Umbra is the same Latin
root that we use for umbrella nice
umbrella umbrella and I'm number or
related words yeah that's cool that's
cool yeah yeah not only that as the Sun
gets more and more eclipsed and there's
a thinner and thinner sliver the source
of light becomes more point-like and we
take for granted what our shadows look
like on the street
you all have fuzzy edges but you don't
think about it because that's just your
shadow as the Sun gets narrower and
narrower it will cast a shadow the way
stage lights will cast a shadow with
very sharp edges and all of a sudden
this is what Joe alluded to earlier
there's an eerie effect that takes place
around you shadows look different they
are more precise they're sharp
they're very they're you're in and
you're in an otherworldly landscape
during these last few moments of the
Eclipse and I sound like an LSD trip
then that last little bit of the Sun Joe
what we call that that last a little bit
we call it the diamond ring the dominant
or the last or Baily's beads Baily's
beads what I like time give a
disappointment for that so the diamond
ring effect is that last a little bit
but it's bright on top and you can still
see the outline of the moon so it looks
like a wedding
right yeah yeah there are going to gauge
me an engagement ring yeah that's cool
so we got to end it there thanks for
thanks for videoing in to Startalk thank
you for inviting me and good luck to all
who are going to be at the Eclipse on
Monday use the 21st Joe doesn't take
luck and take knowledge anyone Chuck hey
love you man I love me too
all right you've been watching possibly
listening to Startalk and we've been
recording this live at the Mashable
World Headquarters the Mashable Universe
headquarters in New York City I've been
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson Chuck nice
Joe rail on video I been your personal
astrophysicist and until next time I bid
you to keep looking up if you like this
please remember everything that we do
can be found commercial-free
plus exclusive original content all on
Startalk all-access calm